it was obviously exciting game let's
look at my sack in the F final draft
let's take us back to this play um what
was going through my mind so literally
we was running fourman games obviously
they was sliding chipping things like
that and I was like man if we get a
opportunity we should go to a fiveman uh
pressure uh and you can see jron Cur
coming off the edge I knew I would end
up getting a one-on-one with a guy that
I knew I could beat I just hit it
relentlessly they still try to come uh
you know double team me but I just was
able to break through and get the
crucial sack that we needed uh to end
the help in the game cuz then of course
my guy Gilly loock the man the guy that
came to help this win the Super Bowl
came over and ended the game and that's
what he do man Gilly loocks a legend
Hall of Famer and you know he told me
when he was at the coach he was thinking
about coming over here I got excited um
but man I'm so glad he came over here
the wisdom uh the type of guy he is bro
I couldn't be more happy uh to play with
a guy like that uh I say I do got to
play with an extra gear in uh in a time
like that especially you know coming off
a big L um coming off you know a time
where a lot of people may have doubt uh
you know a lot of people were saying
some things I was like let let me just
let me just hang back a little bit let
me just show these people what I got and
you know we practiced them situations so
much time offense defense um going
against Tyron in them positions Zack
Martin uh in them positions Tyler Smith
uh just giving me those great looks that
when I go out to and see other guys it's
just it's just nothing but it's not it's
just it's just no it's like no one that
can compare to them those are guys I
think Tyler Smith's gonna be a pro bowl
guy and obviously tyre and exact what
they've done so man those situations we
practice all the time so you know coach
came to me on the sideline was like Hey
You Gotta Go end this game and you know
that was my mentality soon as I stepped
on the field all tired or not we just
had let everything loose so that was
really exciting um my thoughts on the
Chargers this season I think they're a
great team uh they're not far off uh it
sucks losing Mike Williams the way they
did I think you add Mike Williams with
Keenan Allen and it just changes their
whole thing like losing Mike Williams is
so crucial um and you know I kind of
talked about a pre-draft trying to get
Quin Johnson to replace Mike Williams is
hard you know especially coming in the
league you gotta grow you gotta learn
the system you gotta learn uh the smart
routes things like that to make it
easier for your quarterback um but it's
also hard uh so you know losing Mike
Williams is definitely uh tough but I
think they still have a great defense uh
the way that I seen them contain our
offense a little bit um but we also made
some explosive plays and we'll get more
into that later but the Chargers they're
very close away they losing these games
they lost to the Dolphins by a small
margin they lost to us by a small margin
uh they're this close to being a very
good team so uh I think they're on their
way they're sprouting up they're doing
what they're supposed to do besides that
the energy was great in La every time
time I've been to La it's been an
amazing atmosphere I played the Chargers
my rookie year amazing uh I played the
Rams my second year been amazing and
playing the charges again and Sofi is
amazing they obviously have a top three
stadium in the NFL I mean Cowboys Nation
I felt like that was a home game like
y'all took over the stadium that game
was so electric like we all felt the
energy the whole way I mean we see JayZ
and LeBron at the game last night um
it's kind of weird because LeBron also
mentioned that he wasn't a Cowboys fan
anymore so we could take a look at
that you know after LeBron's admitting
that he's not a Cowboys fan it's kind of
weird to see him here but you know
LeBron said he used to be a Cowboys fan
now he's a Cleveland Fan listen braon
this is what I'm gonna say to you
bro I I feel you on that but listen we
here you know your boy here I see you
talk highly of me listen the dogs is
here bro come on braon stay true to who
you want to be with you want to be with
Cowboys Nation come back bro like keep
believing like same I I remember talking
to Jay-Z at the white party he's like
man just seemed like y'all just not
hungry no more well Jay and brown we
hungry we coming we we still trying to
grow keep believing hey don't give up on
us yet but listen we gonna get into
Cleveland in the second we're going to
get into Cleveland in the second just be
prepared for that I don't want to ruin
it too early but we're getting back into
Cleveland a second um but you know also
we got to talk about Troy Aman's comment
about him saying Jay-Z is his
doppelganger I just want to say hold on
Troy hold on I don't know where you got
this from um but this is so far off this
is so far off um I do not see this at
all I don't know where you could be
finding this um this was actually just
insane of a comment like just completely
far off I do not see the resemblance at
all come on Troy um just just know we
got to end that right now um but I
hadn't had a chance to see everything
from last night but I heard there was a
crazy Chargers fan um that's been going
viral I've been seeing her everywhere uh
this was actually insane she had to be
some type of fake person like I don't
know who this came from like where she
came from um but this was a very
depressing woman like there's just no
way like the highs and lows in football
are really crazy and one of a kind so
this was actually kind of funny to see